[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 choisir
vos idées sorties dans le département on
commence ensuite avec le sommaire
sublimer les notion d'échec et d'anti
héros dans un spectacle avec you're
beautiful loser c'est le metteur en
scène frédéric sonntag propose une pièce
de théâtre entre fantastique et biopic
une boutique de créateurs au coeur de la
cité royale ses capsules market le
magasin propose différents ateliers
créatifs et ce même à thème nous
recevrons la cofondatrice philippines
près pain pour nous en parler enfin dans
votre rendez vous dédié aux juniors il
sera question d'informatique et de code
mélanie poquet nous expliquera comment
créer son propre jeu vidéo grâce aux
ateliers proposés au centre alfred de
vigny
tout d'abord un rendez vous à noter ses
week-ends pour les joueurs petits et
grands experts ou non la ville de
villepreux organise la deuxième édition
du festival du jeu plus de 2000 m²
déclinée en différents espaces jeux de
plateau jeux de rôles jeux vidéo espace
jeunesse et jeux grandeur nature l'accès
libre samedi de 15 heures à minuit et
dimanche de 13 heures à 18 heures en
écoute sylvain marc directeur de la
médiathèque le nautilus il organise ce
festival il était au micro de patrick
jacq phoenix maiden sur le festival il
ya une nouveauté c'est les jeux de
figurines cette année il va y avoir une
initiation puis un tournoi
x wings qui est un jeu donc c'est un jeu
de combat la star wars donc ça c'est on
est content de l'avoir parce que pour le
coup c'est un
c'est une licence qui est très porteuse
évidemment et puis c'est un super joli à
voir toutes ces tables avec des
vaisseaux spatiaux partout c'est des
vrais maquette sur laquelle il joue on a
tous types de tout type de jeu avec tout
type de niveau entre guillemets de
l'accueil de 10 du débutant jusqu'à des
jeux un peu pointu qui commenceront
peut-être plus dans la fin de soirée par
exemple autres festivals également ce
week-end mais de cinéma cette fois à
bois d'arcy c'est celui de la bande
annonce il revient cette année pour une
deuxième édition avec une nouveauté le
béaba junior ce dimanche le public est
un vide et est invité à découvrir en
famille les bandes annonces des
prochaines sorties des films jeune
public la projection sera suivie d'un
goûter jean-philippe luce élus de la
commune en charge de la culture au micro
de milani poker nous en dit plus
l'année dernière donc on lançait du
festival la bande annonce cette année on
fait un un déploiement complémentaires
puisqu'on va le dimanche se faire une
session juniors donc le béaba junior à
partir de 16 heures l'objectif étant de
donner envie aux jeunes et aux moins
jeunes puisque les voitures pour la
plupart accompagnés de leurs parents
voire grands parents de venir au cinéma
et découvrir les bandes annonces par la
thématique est un peu différente puisque
l'objectif est de montrer aux enfants et
aux jeunes publics les bandes annonces
des films qui vont sortir tout au long
de l'année prochaine
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première rentrée de capsules
marque est ouverte en avril 2016 cette
boutique de créateurs situé à versailles
a inauguré cette premier atelier avec
nos philippines près pain co fondatrice
de cette boutique pour nous présenter le
concept bonjour philippines à bonjour
alors un petit mot sur votre boutique
vous proposer des ateliers mais
également des produits de créateurs on
trouve un petit peu de tout dans vos
capsules absolument alors pour revenir
simplement à nos débuts on a créé
l'association est à peu près trois ans
au départ c'était quelques événements
créateur ponctuelle à l'année et puis il
ya un an nous a proposé une boutique qui
est là avec ma cousine
céline qui est graphiste on a sauté
dessus on s'est dit on y va et banques
qu on a converse la boutique en avril
dernier et depuis c'est une succession
de non-stop de créateurs puisqu'en fait
notre concept pour en revenir au concept
c'est de louer des emplacements qui
s'appelle des capsules au créateur donc
on a à peu près une quinzaine de
capsules dans la boutique le créateur la
loue à la semaine puisque ça se passe à
la semaine et d'autres petits concept un
peu différent des autres c'est que le
créateur a un jour de présence à la
boutique par semaine ce qui fait que ça
lui permet de rencontrer et la clientèle
qui n'a pas l'habitude de rencontrer et
en même temps d'autres créatrices et il
expose ses oeuvres également donc là
vous avez ramené quelques petites vidéos
produits alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous montrer un petit peu qu'est ce
qu'on peut trouver un type l'eau dans
votre vin capsule marque est déjà voilà
ça tous ces capsules mairie a droit
alors vraiment je fais juste peut-être
remettre un petit
souci le chemisier
ce n'est pas les avait uniquement les
bij le collier enfin ma bague non plus
de fiançailles mais tous ces bijoux la
dallas ont là ce sautoir et alors j'ai
objets qu'on a sur la loi la table alors
alors celui ci se présente parce que on
y tient spécialement à l'inauguration
notre boutique on a fait donc une petite
fête et voilà une de nos créatrice le
plus aux chansons elle arrive de
créatrice nous a fait ce photophores
capsule market the place to be parce que
en effet c'est l'endroit où il faut être
donc voilà ça c'est un de nos objets on
a une créatrice qui on aime beaucoup il
nous fait de magnifiques où elles seront
des coussins alors bon il ya toutes
sortes on a rapporté un seul on a une
créatrice toute récente on a
complètement craqué céline un joli sac
il s'appelle pollux pour ceux qui aiment
fm ciboure pourquoi la torture
exactement après de la porcelaine alors
ça c'est magnifique poster un petit
tabac par diaby au soleil exactement
pour celles dessinées à la main et puis
bon je vous apporte un petit cadeau
quand même à pour la rédaction là
exactement là on aura une grosse marque
est the place to be ce rêve va pour noël
alors c'est parti enjouaillez donc du
coup justement noël on imagine que vous
avez peut-être des petits des ateliers
en résonance avec ces périodes là
également une semaine du bio à venir
voilà alors dans dix jours c'est du 14
au 19 30 pas 14 au 20 c semaine du bio
où nous aurons en fait et des ateliers
ou pour prendre soin de soi des masques
choses comme ça donc tout ce qui est bio
et puis on aura aussi des créatrices qui
font des cosmétiques donc tout ce qui
est shampoing savon et on aura aussi des
budgets on aura aussi de l'alimentaire
avec
des chutes mais des confitures des
petites choses comme ça voilà le début
est donc pas les prochains ateliers à
suivre ce pour s'inscrire c'est plutôt
exactement perdre des noyaux on va avoir
des ateliers régulièrement le samedi
alors ça peut être en duo alors ce qui
est très bien ses parents enfants avec
les enfants avec leurs parents font une
décoration de noël ou font un cadeau ça
avec le font eux-mêmes pendant deux ou
trois heures avec une créatrice qui est
là pour ça très bien pas écouté merci
beaucoup aux philippines prétendent est
revenu sur le pré sur notre plateau pour
nous présenter capsule markets une
nouvelle boutique on le rappelle à
versailles toutes les informations et
les dates des différents ateliers sont à
retrouver sur le site internet merci
beaucoup au final on prend maintenant la
direction du prisme d'elancourt où sera
joué ce soir beautiful losers de
frédéric sonntag un spectacle composé de
deux pièces un diptyque qui pose une
réflexion sur la notion d'échec et deux
antihéros plus de détails dans ce
reportage
[Musique]
hu
médiocre lâche paul est un scientifique
mal dans sa peau son travail va changer
sa vie après un incident dans son
laboratoire il se voit doté de super
pouvoirs
[Musique]
des pouvoirs qui vont devenir de plus en
plus dévorant dans cette pièce frédéric
sonntag revisite le mythe de l'antihéros
cette course au succès que la société
nous impose et bahia des personnages qui
sont un petit peu à côté qui arrive pas
et j'aimais bien l'idée de raconter
aussi l'histoire de ce qui tombe de ceux
qui trébuche de ceux qui qui sont pas
qu'ils arrivent pas complètement rentrer
dans le costume et il faut faire le
récit de ces gens là aussi tu n'en croit
pas ses yeux
du broker de demain
[Musique]
un spectacle joué pour la première fois
sous forme de diptyque beautiful loser
ces composés de l'icann man et de
l'histoire de the shaggs considéré comme
le plus mauvais groupes de rock de tous
les temps les deux destins se répondent
et se rejoignent frédéric sonntag joue
avec les codes des comics et du biopic
seconde mythologique qui appelle
l'utilisation de l'image d'utilisation
de la musique donc il ya de la musique
en direct sur scène qui est jouée par
deux musiciens iliad et beaucoup de
vidéos aussi beaucoup de l'image on
utilise beaucoup l'image pour pouvoir
raconter ce qui est à la fois d'un côté
le principe du biopic c'est à dire
l'histoire d'un groupe de rock et
comment ce groupe va naître et va
évoluer avec un peu tous les motifs
habituel du super héros et en même temps
de l'autre côté tous les motifs habituel
aussi de l'histoire d'un groupe de rock
on va reprendre tous ces motifs la pour
les analyser les regarder voire un peu
aussi l'affluence de ces figures là sur
notre imaginaire des figures sublimer
dans l'échec des perdants réunis sous
une même réflexion sur la popularité et
le prix à payer pour l'atteindre
mans dans le cadre de ce spectacle le
prisme propose des stages de théâtre ce
week-end avec le metteur en scène les
ateliers en lien avec l'imaginaire de la
culture pop développer dans beautiful
loser à savoir le groupe de rock et la
figure du super héros plus de plus
d'informations pour participer sur le
site internet du prisme on passe
maintenant à notre rendez vous dédié aux
juniors avec mélanie poquet
[Musique]
bonjour mélanie vous nous avez rejoint
en plateau pour nous parler de jeux
vidéo et de programmation au centre
alfred de vigny de voisins-le-bretonneux
des cours d'informatique sont proposés
c'est ça bonjour qu'émile déjà de
l'informatique vous l'avez dit mais
aussi de la programmation de
l'imagination et de la logique toutes
ces notions sont à découvrir au centre
alfred de vigny ce sont des ateliers qui
se passe tous les mercredis et les
jeudis s'adresse aux jeunes âgés de 8 à
13 ans pour des questions d'âge et de
compréhension il y a deux groupes les 8
10 ans et les 11 13 ans alors quand on
dit programmation code matt logique ça
ça paraît un peu par un peu barbare en
fait un peu barbare peut-être pour les
adultes qui sont pas très loin en maths
mais les jeunes à prendre apprennent
très vite et en plus l'animateur de
l'atelier raymond pelli c est un
informaticien de métier à l'ordre lors
de ces ateliers il commence bien sûr à
leur apprend les bases une fois qu'elles
sont apprises on passe à des algorithmes
plus complexe plus complexe et coûteuse
ça fonctionne énormément bien parce
qu'il s'aperçoit qu'ils peuvent très
facilement arriver à des résultats et
donc ils apprennent à la fois à coder
donc l'idée c'est pas juste
leur donner des notions mais petit à
petit leur apprendre aussi ce que c'est
que coder un programme est donc comme
ils ont des résultats rapidement mais
ils sont motivés ils sont concentrés ils
arrivent à faire les choses
alors du coup mélanie qu'est ce que
c'est le but de ces ateliers tout
simplement de créer un jeu vidéo ou une
carte animée pour ceux qui le souhaitent
ils travaillent sur le logiciel scratch
un logiciel américain qui permet la
création d'histoires interactive de
dessins animés de jeu bien sûr mais
aussi de compositions musicales donc y
en a pour tous les goûts et surtout il
est adapté aux enfants on leur a donné
la parole écoutée c'est tout simple mais
juste à cliquer sur tel que vous tête tu
fais un truc génial pour l'instant pris
à faire à faire déplacer notre
personnage et quand ils touchent quelque
chose qui fasse une action
alors pour ceux qui aimeraient se lancer
le logiciel scratch est disponible
gratuitement sur internet
ceux qui aimeraient être accompagné
direction le centre alfred de vigny les
coordonnées s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et puis qui sait parmi vos enfants peut
être le prochain concepteur d'un futur
pokémon ou fish a peut-être de nouvelles
vocations chez vos enfants en tout cas
merci beaucoup mélanie poquet de nous
avoir présenté ses ateliers on passe
maintenant à l'agenda les événements à
ne pas manquer
[Applaudissements]
trois rendez vous à noter tout d'abord
le musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines propose un parcours
qu'augmenter à la recherche des reliques
perdues de 50 1 6 km de balade avec des
historiens qui donneront des anecdotes
sur le patrimoine de l'agglomération dès
demain l'espace albert camus de maurepas
accueillera une exposition de patchwork
une cinquantaine d'oeuvres cousu et
assemblé à la main par les adhérents de
l'atelier piqué patch à découvrir
jusqu'au 13 novembre le théâtre alphonse
daudet propose d'embarquer pour un
voyage musical et cinématographique avec
sound tracks le concert s'inspire des 10
des compositeurs de musique de films et
du cinéma et comme c'est la fin de ce
set 8 loisirs je vous propose de nous
quitter en musique en écoute un extrait
très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]